afghan officials say the number of
people killed in multiple blasts near a
school in kabul has risen to 50.
the explosions went off in a largely
sheer muslim neighborhood that's faced
attacks by the so-called islamic state
in recent years
no group has so far claimed
responsibility afghanistan's president
is blaming the taliban
but it's denied the attack instead
pointing the finger at
is militants
just hours before there were school
children preparing for the future
now their covered bodies lie on a
hospital floor
it is a site that has become all too
common in afghanistan
multiple blasts went off outside the
syed al shakhtar school in western kabul
as lessons ended for the day many of the
children killed would have been on their
way home
to break the ramadan fast with their
families
i was with my classmate we were leaving
school when suddenly an explosion
happened
my classmate was killed ten minutes
later another explosion and then a third
one
everyone was screaming and there was
blood everywhere i couldn't see anything
clearly
the attack comes just eight days after a
truck bomb
at a university entrance south of kabul
left 27 people dead
from kabul i'm joined by journalist ali
latifi
ali this is the second attack in as many
weeks
and the u.s is slowly pulling out of
afghanistan
is the security situation deteriorating
i don't think it's deteriorating i don't
think it was very good to begin with
these sorts of attacks were taking place
while the us was here
it's certainly not as if the us was
stationed outside girls schools or
any other schools are actively
protecting civilian targets
in afghanistan unfortunately this has
just been the situation
in the country over the last several
years
um and that's just the sad reality of
the country at the moment
ali the target as you say seems to have
been a girl's
school what does that tell us
it look as as you said earlier in the
video package you know just
a week or two prior another group of
students in bogata province also came
under attack um you know it's a way of
attacking the young people of the
country the future of the country i went
to that neighborhood today in kabul
where the attack took place
and i spoke to several families who
lived in the nearby area who lived near
the pool
who said that their children
specifically their daughters were now
like
at night they were crying they were
saying if we go don't send us to school
please don't send us to school if you
send us to school we'll die
going to school will mean death um and
the mothers are now trying to convince
their children to go back to you know
saying
you'll take a break for a while but you
have to go back you have to continue
your education um so this is definitely
you know
having the impact that whoever is behind
it is wanting it to have
which is basically a making people feel
as if they're not secure
or solidifying the fact that they don't
feel secure and
also for the younger generations
especially the youngest ones you know
the mother we were speaking
to she was saying her children were six
and nine years old it's creating a fear
of public institutions
things that are essential like a school
like an education you know uh people in
the area were saying if you look
look at what's being targeted it's
mosques it's schools it's education
centers it's hospitals
um you know these are all basic services
of everyday life
thank you very much for the update
journalist ali latifi in kabul